okay so the topic of this video will be
kind of how to build a graph and kind of
some of the differences between a line
graph and a bar graph so let's get
started well first of all some of the
graphing basics you know why why do we
build a graph in the first place well a
graph helps us to better visualize data
that's been collected in an experiment
perhaps graphs help us to observe if
there are any patterns and trends you
can see in this graph there's a downward
pattern in the decay rate of carbon-14
if you've ever heard of radiometric
dating over time carbon will decay and a
relatively known rate and pattern it's
nice to visually see that and lastly you
know graphs help us to better summarize
large amounts of data you've probably
heard the expression a picture's worth
pictures worth a thousand words so we
can say things with thousands upon words
or we can show a picture and often show
that information even better than
thousands of words might do well first
of all the graph you see here this is a
line graph notice how it is showing
changes over a long period of time over
forty thousand years has taken place in
this particular graph and that's why
we've chosen a line graph
whenever you're showing changes that
occur over a period of time in most
cases you're gonna opt to do a line
graph well how does that differ from a
bar graph now this graph right here
being a bar graph we're comparing sets
of data what we're actually comparing
this kind of a fun little graph here it
compares the odds of rolling two dice in
getting a three or a five or a eight so
what if you were to roll an 11 you see
from the bar you have just under a six
percent chance of rolling an 11 compare
that to the odds of rolling an eight
from the bar you can see just under a 14
percent chance
of rolling 1/8 so if you're comparing
sets of data here side by side it's nice
to see a bar graph ok so here's some
data right here and if you notice what
the data is showing it shows how the
population in the United States has
changed from 1980 to 2015 if I were to
ask you to graph this data based on what
we just discussed what do you think a
line graph or a bar graph I hope you
would recognize this would be a line
graph because we are showing how the
population of the United States has
changed over a period of time from 1980
to 2015 well look at this set of data
right here this is the Year 2016 it's
the population size of these six states
right here in this example I hope you
realize a bar graph would be best
because we're comparing California to
Illinois to New York the Florida to
Texas to Washington and it's all for the
same year 2016 so we're not showing
anything changing over a period of time
we're just comparing side-by-side
so let's start with this information we
just saw this a moment ago this is the
population of the USA and how it's
changed from 1980 to 2015 and we're
gonna make a line which means we're
gonna display how the changes have
occurred over this period of time well
here is our same data I just had to
create a little bit of space because
we're gonna put our graph grid grid
right here in this area here now let's
talk about a few needs first let's start
with the title how about my lab graph I
hope you see that's just not acceptable
it doesn't tell me anything
well then how about science data again
this doesn't really tell me anything
how about people well that's a little
better at least it tells me people are
involved but it's still so vague how
about something specific people in the
USA from 1980 to 2015 be specific to the
readers of your graph so now we're gonna
focus on a label for the x-axis and
that's along the bottom and the general
rule for a change over time graph is the
time unit goes along the x axis so can I
just say time well I hope you realize
that's not good enough B there's lots of
ways to measure time days weeks months
econds in this case years so that means
I should just say years right well
that's better but still we have to do a
little bit better
we actually yes we actually have to
state that years is the unit of time and
if you're wondering why doesn't
everybody know that years is a way to
measure time or that minutes is a way to
measure time yeah and those examples I
think that is universally known but what
if you're measuring in physics and
chemistry class what if you measuring
something in joules is that universally
known for what that what a dual measures
I don't think so or maybe in physics
you're measuring something in Newton's I
don't think that's universally
understood what a Newton measures and
also a Pascal is a Pascal something that
is you
Worsley known so because you might
encounter some measurements that are not
universally known yes we do have to
state time and then in parentheses we
can say years or minutes or weeks in
this case it would be years okay so now
let's focus on a label for the y-axis
and a general rule here the y-axis is
the dependent variable it's the data
being measured well what are we
measuring from 1980 to 2015 we're
measuring the population size in
millions of people so let's keep it just
like that nice and simple well now we
have to focus on properly setting up the
data couple rules number one keep your
spacing consistent and the intervals
between numbers must be consistent so
for instance can I do this well I hope
you see which rule we just violated we
violated the spacing must be consistent
notice how there are three gaps between
1980 and 1985 and then down to two gaps
and then back to three gaps and then two
gaps and then three gaps and two gaps
and three gaps this will end up
distorting the shape of our line graph
once we were to actually create it so
how about this
can we do this notice how the spacing
looks fine but we violated the interval
a rule from a moment ago between 19 and
880 and 1985 is a gap of 10 excuse me
five years and then between 85 and 90 is
a gap of five years but then there's a
gap of ten years and then down to five
years and then five years again and then
back to ten years this also would
distort the shape of our line graph if
we were to do this and so that's the
reason why we have to keep everything
consistent so how about something like
this the spacing looks pretty good the
intervals look pretty good I'm happy
with this do I have to create a spacing
where I use every single square of my
graph grid
no even though 2015 ends just before the
end of the grid that's fine we've spaced
it out the intervals are good now we're
going to focus on the y-axis thinking
about how can we label this how can we
number the y-axis well do we have to
start at zero and then go from zero
upward maybe 50 100 150 do we have to
start at zero and the answer is no we
don't when you look at the data so why
not just start at zero well look at the
low number 227 million it's a smallest
number we have to graph the biggest
number 320 million if we were to create
the graph the entire graph would be
crammed in this yellow highlighted area
here not that that's a horrible thing
but it's a lot of wasted graphing area
where we could space it out better to
make it a little easier to analyze for
our readers so how about this example
something like this well if you look I
hope you realize we violated the
interval rule notice how there is a gap
of 20 million people in between 220 and
240 and then 20 million here and then 10
million 10 million 10 million back to 20
million down to 10 million if we were to
do this it would distort the shape of
our final graph so how about something
like this everything looks pretty good
I've used intervals of 20 million all
the way up and everything looks fine
notice how we started around 220 and
proceeded upward now we have to plot our
accurate data points so when I look at
the graph I see 1980 227 million so draw
an imaginary line where 1980 and 227
would inner intersect and put a nice big
blue dot there 1985 238
put a a data point there 1990 has 250
million 1995 266 million 2000 282
million 2005 295 million 2010 310
million and 2015 320 million well now
what well it's a line graph well in some
examples you may just want to connect
the dots and one dot leads to another
dot leads to another DEATH now depending
on the graph you make this might be
sufficient but in some graphs you might
want to do what's called a best fit
graph where you just kind of draw a
straight line
it's more of an average and the way you
kind of generally create these is half
of the dots are on one side of the
straight line the other half are on the
other side this is more of an average
I'm not gonna go into this video on when
you should do a best-fit versus just
connecting the dots that's something
that you may learn a little bit later on
so here I've settled on I just ran my
general connected graph here what if I
had a second country what if I had a
second country to compare well now I
could connect these dots and what's
missing if I were comparing the United
States to this other country what's
missing is a key how do I know which
color is which country and so maybe
throw a key in right there so the blue
line represents the USA the darker
brownish line represents the other
country that we might be comparing to so
you can see you can have multiple lines
on a line graph just choose different
colors to distinguish which is which
well let's come to this a bar graph this
is a good way to compare data and we're
comparing the six states their
population size in the year 2016 I can
compare them so here's our data and my
area for the graph grid and some needs
here again let's start with a title
how about States again it's it's too
vague
how about amount of people well it's
better I know people are involved but
too vague be specific how about the
population size in the year 2016 now I'm
clear to the reader of my graph well now
let's actually start with the y-axis
again this is the dependent variable the
data being measured how about a label
for this how about just population size
in millions of people well now we're
going to shift to the x axis and so what
do you think a good label for our x axis
might be what can go down here and I
hope you realize it that would be the
states of the United States that we're
gonna be graphing we're gonna be
graphing six of these of the states here
California through Washington so now we
have to set up our our data here and so
we're gonna focus on the y axis again
the rules spacing must be consistent and
the intervals must be consistent the
loan number we have to graph is
Washington at seven million and the high
number is 39 now seven is close enough
to zero or I might go ahead and actually
start at zero and go all the way up but
I hope you see what rule I violated I
violated the intervals notice how
there's an interval of two at the start
and then around the halfway mark
interval of four interval of eight
interval of eleven interval of five this
is going to end up distorting the shape
of my graph if I were to continue
so again here is a better example
starting maybe around zero because again
Washington x7 is close enough to zero
and I went every four million all the
way up and now I have to draw accurate
bars a couple rules the bar spacing
needs to be consistent the bar width
should be consistent and because we're
not creating a histogram in this graph
the bars really should not touch there
are types of bar graphs called
histograms where the bars do touch those
measures something very different so in
this case bars would not touch and so
for California has around 39 million and
I'm gonna draw my bar Illinois has
around 13 million so I'll draw my bar
New York has around 20 million Florida
has around 21 million Texas 28 million
and Washington 7 million
well what's missing in this graph well I
hope it's pretty obvious what's missing
a label for the bars now that we've
identified California if you're
Washington this graph is really finished
I have a nice concise title I have
proper spacing and and intervals on the
bars they're all drawn accurately I've
used most of my graph grid I didn't try
to squeeze the entire graph and of the
lower corner and this would be a fine
acceptable graph right here now what's
wrong with this graph well I hope you
see what's wrong with this graph the bar
width should be consistent in this case
I have skinny bars and fat bars I'm
supposed to pay attention to how tall
the bars are not how narrow or wide they
are this makes me think that there's
something significant about the
narrowness or the fatness of the bar
when in reality there isn't it's the
tallness of the bar that matters well
what's wrong with this example I hope
you see what's wrong is the spacing is
not consistent by doing this by
isolating Washington away from all the
other bars you're making me think that
there's something unique
Washington so having consistent spacing
in between the bars it is really quite
helpful in me organizing this in my mind
and how about this one so the the most
noticeable thing here is the colors I
think because there's nothing wrong with
the spacing the bar widths are
consistent and the bars are not touching
so the thing is in this case the colors
really serve no purpose other than maybe
making it pretty and of course having a
visually attractive graph can be really
helpful but we really want the graphs to
be functional so in this case they
really serve no purpose
as we wrap up this video here I'm just
gonna leave you with this compare and
contrast and I hope you found this video
helpful and thank you for watching